what do we do they tell us at the
station to come down here and felt time
but uh there's no story here this
neighborhood there's always a story here
give me the name of a mythical creature
mythical I don't trust me I don't know
Pegasus Pegasus perfect just roll watch
and learn Nichols beat channel 6 news
we've had reports of a Pegasus in the
area as anything like that curiosity has
brought out large crowds to see the
alleged Pegasus in this South Lennox
neighborhood I'm gonna find it break it
Andy ride it to the Pegasus treasure
residents say the creature resembles of
this amateur sketch keep the dumb mock
our city's got to pay for that too I
ain't got no cover sittin up there every
day while many revel in the possibility
of seeing the winged horse others are
not so welcoming I just know this
neighborhood will be better if that pega
did you put down I tell you this God I
ain't puttin our weddings on no horse
now see if this was a white neighborhood
Animal Control will be up in here with a
Pegasus trap that's right they can't
take our Pegasus this is all Pegasus
here
a man where you interrupting me I'm
trying to talk about the Pegasus hey
don't be disrespecting Pegasus yes we're
here live on the scene in South Lennox
where riots have broken out over the
alleged appearance of a flying horse
[Music]